[Music]
china has been building up the biggest
real estate bubble the world has ever
seen
and it looks like the ponzi scheme is
finally starting to crack and if it does
there is actually a legitimate chance it
could bring down the entire chinese
economy with it and that is not a
sensational exaggeration to get views
let me explain
here's what you have to understand about
china unlike the us who has enjoyed the
good life in every way imaginable since
world war ii the prosperity you see in
china with this fancy skyscraper cities
money and wealth is a very recent thing
just a generation ago chinese people
were absolutely suffering with famines
and cannibalism and massacres and
violent purges and exiles and a bunch of
other disturbing stuff that we can't
talk about without getting demonetized
which is why you should click that join
button below for our uncensored
documentaries we're going to be
releasing a few on some of these
disturbing subjects including forced
organ harvesting and all of this
suffering was thanks to the beauty of
communism
and the consequence of communism is that
the plus weren't allowed to own anything
chinese people cannot own a home like
you and i can they couldn't even own a
square foot of land to grow their own
food on i mean after all you wouldn't
want to be a greedy capitalist now would
you but then the chinese government came
to their senses they looked at the west
and saw just how powerful it was when
the plebs you rule over feel like they
could own stuff that i can own my home
that if i work hard i can buy an even
nicer home or a nicer car
when in reality plebs in the west don't
own anything if you don't believe me
don't pay your property taxes and see
what happens
people in the west just feel that
they're able to own stuff and because
they feel like they have a sense of
ownership they actually work hard it's
insane right people will actually work
hard if it's for their own selfish
benefit and not some communist ideal who
would have thought and if you were the
chinese government at this time this was
revolutionary you're telling me that all
i have to do to fix my poor broken
country is let my peasants feel as if
they have ownership
sign me up
but hold on you don't want to give them
too much freedom now you still want to
keep your power over your plebs while
giving them the feeling of ownership
so instead of going full capitalists
like the west you decide to just give
them a little taste of capitalism to get
them working while keeping absolute
control so you give your plebs some
economic freedom you allow them to start
businesses you open up china to the west
for foreigners to throw money into china
and most importantly you give them the
illusion that they can own property that
they can buy a house own a home when in
reality there is still no private
ownership of land in china your plebs
simply get a land lease from you that
only lasts 70 years they don't actually
own their home but it worked
plebs got that feeling of ownership and
it made all the difference because
remember your peasants were staring
death in the face every single day
because they couldn't own land and now
that they could buy real estate now that
they could own their home it was a
really big deal for them so people
started pouring their life savings into
buying homes and then foreign investors
saw all this progress and decided that
they wanted to invest in this fast
growing economy so they started pouring
money into china and all of a sudden
china's economy started becoming the
fastest growing economy on the face of
the planets things were getting better
more prosperous but to your plebs they
grew up living through hell they don't
think all this newfound prosperity is
gonna last they definitely don't trust
your currency they know it's complete
trash and if you think your currency is
trash why would you keep any cash you
would want to convert as much of that
cash as possible into something that
will hold its value but your peasants
can't put their money into the stock
market or bonds they can't trust those
things either so all that's left to
preserve their newfound wealth is real
estates and a lot of it
and it was because of these two great
forces chinese families desperately
trying to buy homes and a ton of foreign
money pouring into china and chinese
real estates that home prices in china
psychotically skyrocketed into the
biggest real estate bubble the world has
ever seen and it looks like that bubble
is finally starting to burst
my name is jake tran and we make
documentaries on money power war and
crime so that you can see the world for
what it really is a giant game of
acquiring power you can't get out of
this game either way so instead of being
a victim why not learn to be a better
player your parents teachers friends
society will never teach you any of this
so we're going to
stay dangerous and this is the great
chinese super bubble
side note i will admit that i had a
thing for russian girls at one point so
here's what i did i downloaded this app
called babel one of the top language
learning apps in the world chose russian
as the language i wanted to learn and
boom within a few minutes i learned some
simple russian words like ani duma the
anya spasiba
[Music]
and i can confirm that it definitely
impressed russian women no comment
learning a language is a great way to
impress women or a business person you
want to build rapport with and babel is
the app for the job and today's video
sponsor
unlike most language learning tools
babble teaches you how to have real
conversations that you will actually use
in the real world so you're not just
memorizing random stuff like you did in
your high school language class their 10
minute interactive lessons cover topics
like business travel relationships and
more and the thing that sets babel apart
is their award-winning technology babble
has been empirically proven by academics
from places like yale university to help
you start speaking a new language in
just 3 weeks yes you heard that right
just 3 weeks this is thanks to their top
quality speech recognition that helps
you perfect your pronunciation and
accent on the spots plus other games
videos and even live classes and they
even have a 20-day money-back guarantee
that way you can start learning and see
how far you get before committing over
10 million people have purchased a
babble subscription and they keep coming
back because babble just works so what
new language are you gonna learn
whatever the language is you can start
learning it right now with an extra 60
off your subscription by using my link
in the description below click the link
below for 60 off your babble
subscription now thanks to babel for
sponsoring this video
[Music]
compared to the west chinese society is
rooted in the family not the individual
that means in china it's not just you
saving up to buy a house for yourself
it's you and your entire extended family
pooling together your life savings to
buy a home and every family started
doing this and because everyone started
buying home prices started to climb and
they kept climbing until all of a sudden
prices became unaffordable to the
average family
but look home prices just keep going up
there's no way i can lose if i can just
find a way to get my hands on a home and
that's where loans come in people
started taking out mortgages to buy
homes borrowing money they didn't have
but they were perfectly okay taking out
a loan because again home prices are
only going up it's the same psychology
as a crypto speculator seeing the price
of bitcoin going up they're comfortable
taking out a loan to buy more bitcoin
and the moment loans are introduced into
the game prices skyrocket even higher
because the people that couldn't afford
a home before now suddenly had a lot
more money to spend
and all this new money was competing
over the same homes in the population
centers where everyone actually lived
and worked so home prices would continue
to climb until even people with loans
couldn't afford them anymore but again
we need to buy real estate to preserve
our wealth and if we can't compete for
houses in the cities where people
actually live i guess we'll just have to
buy real estate in surrounding areas
that are much more affordable because no
one lives there enter ghost cities
[Music]
these giant brand new cities are
scattered all over china all filled with
extravagant monuments parks skyscrapers
brand new roads and infrastructure and
yet there's not a soul in sight
it's estimated that there are at least
65 million empty homes in china that's
one-fifth of all the homes in china left
vacant enough to house the entire
population of france with it this is
what happens when you extrapolate out
the scenario we just explained this is
what happens when owning a home is so
ingrained into your culture that you
have to expand your search into worse
and worse locations until you end up
buying a condo and a skyscraper that
isn't finished yet in a city that isn't
finished yet that absolutely no one
lives in
and what people forget is that someone
has to build these residential buildings
someone had to build these ghost towns
someone had to spend the last few
decades making bank off of the chinese
people's insatiable thirst for real
estate and that someone are china's
megalithic property developers
[Music]
as the masses were drooling from the
mouth watching home prices go up and
thus their wealth go up on paper chinese
real estate developers the companies
that built these homes were rolling in
money
they were selling more houses than they
could build
since they couldn't keep up with demand
they thought hmm why don't we just
pre-sell a home meaning why don't we get
the money from the plebs first where
they literally take out a mortgage and
start making mortgage payments before we
even start building their home and boom
it worked
pre-sales went through the roof that
wasn't built yet people were so
desperate to get a home that they
scraped together their down payment from
all their family members they got a
giant mortgage and started making
mortgage payments every single month for
years while their condo was still being
built
imagine paying for a house every single
month for years before it was actually
built at one point demand was so high
that ninety percent of the properties
being built in china were pre-sold
for the developers this was amazing they
got the cash up front and the demand
seemed never ending so logically we got
to start building even more
people are just gonna want more condos
so we might as well go big or go home so
just like how the people felt
comfortable taking life savings and
getting a loan to buy a house because
they saw prices just continue to climb
developers also felt comfortable taking
all the money customers gave them for
pre-sale homes to take out loans to
start even more giant residential towers
and chinese banks and investors happily
supplied them with the debt so much debt
in fact that the second biggest property
developer in china ever grand that
manages enough land to cover the size of
manhattan racked up
305 billion dollars worth of debt more
than any other real estate developer in
the world
to put this into perspective evergrande
had borrowed more money than the entire
gdp of new zealand or finland or
portugal and in 2018 evergrand was named
the most valuable real estate company in
the world
and for a while it was all sunshine and
rainbows the plebs got the feeling of
ownership and social status if they
could get their hands on a home or a
pre-sale home and saw their home values
go up and the developers were growing
like crazy through pre-sales and taking
on massive debt but then
the cracks started to show
how do you know when you're in a real
estate bubble when the price of homes
are way out of touch with how much
people are making during the housing
bubble in america around 2008 home
prices peaked at around seven times
people's median income
seven times what the average person
makes in america that's pretty crazy
side note that ratio is also now even
higher than it was at the housing bubble
peak but that's a story for another
video so make sure you subscribe
now let's see what that number is like
in china at its peak a condo and
shenzhen cost 43 times the average
yearly salary in china and in beijing 42
times
a new home in a major chinese city costs
more than what the average person would
make in over 40 years
even in new york one of the most
expensive cities in america homes cost
just 10 times the average salary
when this happens how much higher can
prices really go how is the regular
working class ever going to be able to
buy a house how much longer can this
really last
hint
it's already collapsing
[Music]
it didn't take long for the chinese
communist party or ccp to realize that
constantly loaning developers money to
build more condos wasn't sustainable
eventually home prices were going to get
too high for people to afford people
would stop buying
prices would nosedive leaving the
industry in chaos and the chinese
economy in crisis it just wasn't an
option so they did the only logical
thing they stopped chinese banks and
investors from giving so many quick and
easy loans to developers
they hoped this would slow down the
number of apartments being built and
helped keep prices stable but they
overlooked one thing
pre-sold homes
these developers had over extended
themselves they needed the never-ending
loans to finish the units they had
already sold
so without the constant never-ending
loans developers quickly ran out of
money to finish the condos people had
already started paying for
remember evergrand the second biggest
property developer in china that was
taking on an insane amount of debt to
grow well recently it just started
missing out on debt repayments which
means they're all out of money which
means they're on the verge of collapse
dozens of china's biggest real estate
developers are also now missing debt
payments
they're literally all on their last
dying breath so what did all of these
developers do they just stopped building
and all their buildings came to a
complete standstill
the same buildings that families
pre-bought and spent years making
mortgage payments for were not being
built anymore
and the people are furious
imagine taking out a home loan paying
your deposit and making monthly mortgage
payments for years believing you were
going to move into your new home soon
only to find out that the company
building your apartment ran out of money
and just stopped building your home
that was the reality millions of chinese
citizens woke up to
combine that with all the suffering
that's been happening in china with
their extreme covet lockdowns and the
people have had enough
why keep making mortgage payments on a
home that was never going to be finished
and so
the mortgage boycotts began
hundreds of thousands of chinese
homeowners in more than 100 cities
banded together and simply stopped
paying their mortgages in protest around
222 billion dollars in home loans are
under threat from mortgage boycotts and
if the majority of people start
boycotting their mortgages it could mean
disaster for the chinese economy
[Music]
so the chinese people are in this weird
situation where families have put not
just their life savings into random
properties that no one lives in but on
top of that they took out loans to buy
these properties
a big chunk of them even bought multiple
homes
so now they have to service those loans
meaning they have to pay off their
mortgage every month so not only did
they lose life savings but a good chunk
of their monthly income is now gone too
and as prices start falling at some
point they're going to have to stop
paying their mortgage and default on
them
and when that happens the entire banking
system is completely screwed because all
those loans they lent out to home buyers
and developers well they had to get that
money from somewhere to be able to lend
it out
and that somewhere came from money that
other people deposited into the bank
everyone from poor chinese families
putting their savings into their bank
account to giant corporations keeping
the money they need in theirs to operate
so if all these loans default they might
not have enough money in the vaults to
pay back their customers deposits
and if word gets out about that there
could be a bank run
and if there's a bank run the banks will
surely fail
and banks failing is just another way of
saying people's life savings will
disappear
and if the banking system fails and
everyone's savings disappears
then the chinese economy
collapses
that's why america bailed out the banks
in 2008 because even though the bankers
deserved to suffer everyone's savings
disappearing will cause a lot more
social unrest
the ccp is very aware of this danger so
they're doing their best to cushion the
fall
right now the ccp has instructed china's
central bank to mobilize 148 billion
dollars to bail out the country's
biggest real estate developers
and yes there's an argument that since
china has strict currency controls where
it's super hard to get money out of
china and they manipulate their currency
to keep their economy under control they
still don't have the same advantage
america has
see when you hear about how america has
an advantage because they have the
reserve currency of the world it's just
another way of saying america has been
blessed with the ultimate power the
power to steal from the rest of the
world through printing money
since the world has to transact in
dollars whenever the us prints money the
rest of the world pays the price
america exports its inflation to the
rest of the world
that is the real power of having the
reserve currency
china does not have such a luxury
china makes money manufacturing stuff
the outside world gives them money that
money gets plowed into speculative real
estate and if that real estate collapses
and the chinese government has to bail
out the banks well they're gonna have to
print money to bail them out and since
they don't have the luxury of being able
to export their inflation to the rest of
the world the chinese people will be the
ones bearing the brunt of the inflation
and the thing about inflation is that it
only ever affects the poor and the
middle class
why because the poor in the middle class
spend money on consumer things consumer
things that they have to keep buying
while it goes up in price
the rich on the other hand spend money
on assets on investments things that
they hold on to that go up in price
the great chinese super bubble is
something the world has never seen
before
and only time will tell if the ccp will
be able to manipulate their economy out
of this
the chinese real estate industry has a
lot wrong with it but it's definitely
not the only business out there with
issues just look at victoria's secret
the world famous lingerie brand that is
known for its angels skinny tan
beautiful models
every year beautiful girls as young as
17 that are willing to do anything for
their career are recruited from all over
the world to walk the runway in
tantalizing lingerie nothing could go
wrong here right well it turns out a
disturbing amount can go wrong because
victoria's secret has a sinister little
secret they'd rather you not know about
you see
les wexner the owner of victoria's
secret is also best friends and business
partners with everyone's favorite
private island owner jeffrey epstein
yep you heard me right
the owner of a lingerie brand that
employs underage girls to model its very
sexy collection was not just business
partners but close friends with the man
that didn't kill himself
strangely close in fact
but here's the thing
releasing a video on the man that didn't
kill himself and his ties to victoria's
secret and all the disturbing stuff they
did would definitely get demonetized so
instead we've released it as a private
documentary uncensored only available to
members of this channel
all you have to do to discover the nasty
truth behind victoria's secret and other
topics like monsanto the company that
owns the world's food supply cia black
sites and the roots of middle eastern
terrorism is to hit that join button
below
once you do you'll have instant access
to all the videos that are just too
risky too controversial to post in
public
and unlike universities we're not going
to squeeze you for thousands of dollars
only for you to walk away knowing
nothing about how the world works all it
takes is five dollars a month to learn
the stuff no parent teacher or boss will
ever teach you
and there's a refund policy too unlike
most youtube memberships so if you join
and you don't think it's worth it email
us within your first month of joining
for the first time and we will
personally refund you for your first
month
after your first month there is no
refund
so people say china is going to collapse
like all the time and when i started
seeing a bunch of videos on youtube
about this i was a little bit wary
because how can you know that china is
going to collapse in exactly 29 days or
whatever but the more i looked into it
the more plausible it seems maybe not in
exactly some specific number of days but
still so hope you guys enjoyed the video
and if you're new here this is one of
the biggest channels on youtube for
documentaries on money power war and
crime so if you enjoy this one there's
multiple videos just like this coming
out every single week and it's all free
too so click on subscribe button below
you can follow me on instagram jaketrain
but that's going to wrap it up stay
dangerous out there and i will see you
guys in the next one
[Music]
you